schutz und hotspot regelung es soll
alles ganz schnell gehen es muss sehr
schnell gehen heute noch die
ausschussberatung morgen gibt es noch
eine bund länder runde da beugen sich
die ministerpräsidentin und präsidenten
auch nochmal drüber am freitag dann hier
bundestag die verabschiedung des
gesetzentwurfes und dann auch eben
bundesrat ja wir haben einen kleinen
ausblick gerade schon gehabt auch das
was den bundestag jetzt in der nächsten
guten stunde beschäftigt wir haben sie
schon gesehen die bundesinnenminister in
nancy faeser es gibt jetzt sie befragen
der bundesregierung mit dem
bundesinnenministerium
ganz herzlichen dank frau präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
habe mir nicht vorstellen können dass
wir einen so furchtbaren
verbrecherischen überfall auf ein großes
land mitten in europa erleben dieser
russische angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine ist eine humanitäre katastrophe
dieser krieg verursacht unendliches leid
ich werde heute nachmittag zur situation
der geflüchteten menschen noch
ausführlicher sprechen dennoch möchte
ich schon jetzt sagen seit dieser
furchtbare krieg begonnen hat bin ich in
sehr engen kontakt mit den ländern
gemeinsam auch mit den kommunen tun wir
alles dafür um den kriegsflüchtlingen
die zu uns kommen schnell und umfassend
zu helfen
ganz überwiegend sind dass frauen und
kinder und ältere menschen wir arbeiten
sehr intensiv an der bestmöglichsten
versorgung unterbringung und verteilung
wie koordinieren die es sehr eng auch
gemeinsam mit dem verkehrsministerium
und der bahn der bund unterstützt die
länder massiv mit dem thw und starken
kräften der bundespolizei und des
bundesamtes für migration und
flüchtlinge
diejenigen die nicht privat bei familien
bei bekannten freunden untergebracht
werden können verteilen wir nun nach dem
königsteiner schlüssel auf die länder
und zugleich spreche ich mit meinen
europäischen amtskollegen über eine
gerechtere verteilung in der gesamten
europäischen union wir haben einen
historischen schulterschluss erreicht
dass alle eu staaten gemeinsam schnell
und unbürokratisch den geflüchteten
helfen meine damen und herren
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle aber
auch schon etwas zur registrierung sagen
damit wir bei den fakten bleiben für
viele ukrainerinnen ukraine gilt
visafreiheit für 90 tage das ist
geltendes recht und das ermöglicht auch
dass viele bereits in andere europäische
staaten weiterreisen trotzdem haben wir
sehr schnell entschieden auch diese
menschen bei der erstaufnahme zu
registrieren und damit zum
frühstmöglichen zeitpunkt das bmz
unterstützt die länder dabei mit
registriert stationen das werden wir
weiter intensivieren die registrierung
erfolgt spätestens wenn menschen
unterstützungsleistungen in der
bundesrepublik brauchen damit haben wir
einen guten überblick und können
koordinieren und steuern meine damen und
herren gerade jetzt angesichts der
bedrohung des friedens in europa müssen
wir den inneren frieden in unserem land
auch stärken wir wissen dass
rechtsextremisten jede krise für ihre
menschenverachtende hetze missbrauchen
aber das wird ihnen auch diesmal nicht
gelingen wir werden das nicht zulassen
auch deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
sehr konkret handeln dazu dient mein
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus den
ich ihnen kurz skizzieren möchte
prävention und härte gehören zusammen
wir werden rechtsextreme netzwerke
zerschlagen
wir werden ihr die finanzaktivitäten
unterbinden wir werden rechtsextremisten
konsequent entwaffnen wir werden
verfassungsfeinde aus dem öffentlichen
dienst entfernen wir werden die
demokratischen streitkultur fördern und
radikalisierung stärker vorbeugen und
wir wollen für einen besseren schutz von
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitikern sorgen meine damen
und herren
alles augenmerk richtet sich gerade auf
den furchtbaren krieg in der ukraine und
diesen folgen aber wir haben den inneren
frieden und unserem land sehr genau im
blick wir bringen in der innenpolitik
das voran was für uns als fortschritts
koalition vorgenommen haben vielen dank
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank für ihre ausführungen
frau bundesministerin und wir beginnen
die regierungsbefragung
mit dem zunächst mit fragen des kollegen
mario czaja rund eine stunde haben die
abgeordneten zeit die innenministerin zu
fragen
der frau bundesministerin die sicherheit
an bahnhöfen und angrenzendes der
aufgabe des bundes in polen wird an der
grenze erfasst wer flüchtende frauen und
kinder mitnimmt und aufnimmt warum ist
das in deutschland bislang nicht möglich
diese menschen zu schützen
ordnete ich habe ihn ja gerade schon
erklärt dass wir das auch tun die
bundespolizei nimmt nach geltendem recht
in deutschland all diejenigen die hier
einreisen über keinen pass verfügen und
drittstaatsangehörige sind und
diejenigen die ohne pass aus der ukraine
einreisen selbstverständlich auf bei
grenzübertritt dafür gibt es die
bearbeitungs straßen der bundespolizei
mit dem dampf und alle anderen werden
fürs möglich in den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen auch in
deutschland registriert das sind meine
nachbarn
frau ministerin sie haben eine frage
nicht beantwortet die frage war wer
erfasst wo die frauen und kinder
aufgenommen werden und wer sie abholt
ich habe ihnen die frage so beantwortet
wie in deutschland der gang der dinge
ist wie wir nehmen diejenigen die mit
biometrischen pass aus der ukraine
kommen hier auf die haben 90 tage
reisefreiheit visumsfreiheit in
deutschland die werden wir wir verteilen
die das habe ich schon gesagt zu den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung dort werden sie
erfasst
also wie eine nachfrage geht und die
frage ist jetzt ob es noch einen
weiteren frage mich von ihnen erteilt
ob noch eine weitere frage zu diesem
themenkomplex gibt mit schönen frau
widmann mauz war zuerst
ja frau ministerin sie haben in einer
pressemitteilung am 10 märz eine
kooperation mit airbnb org und mit
unterkunft ukraine gg sind sie
eingegangen sie suggerieren in dieser
pressemitteilung nicht nur dass es zu
einer strukturierten organisation der
vermittlung von unterkünften kommt
sondern sie signalisieren auch dass es
sich um seriöse
übernachtungsangebote handelt ich frage
sie gibt es bei dieser zusammenarbeit
denn eine prüfung der
vertrauenswürdigkeit der personen der
familien die minderjährige aufnehmen
gehört dazu zum beispiel die vorlage die
verpflichtung der vorlage eines
polizeilichen führungszeugnisses
oder sind die organisationen die
verpflichtung eingegangen die mieter
darauf hinzuweisen dass sie sich bei den
ausländerbehörden registrieren lassen
soll vor abgeordnete ich dann gehen für
ihre frage diejenigen die dort anbieten
auf deren homepage wir verweisen haben
sich dazu verpflichtet dass sie darauf
achten dass nur seriöse angebote dort
vermittelt werden das sind nur große
vermittler von wohnraum es sind eben
keine die dort privat noch mal
zusätzlich anbieten und insofern haben
wir darauf verwiesen ich weiß im übrigen
darauf hin dass wir diese woche eine
eigene plattform zur verfügung stellen
werden wo wir auf diese angebote
hinweisen und dann eine entsprechende
hilfe stelle für die ukrainischen
geflüchteten auch zur verfügung gestellt
wird das geht diese woche an den start
herzlichen dank die nächste frage kommt
von kollegen leon eckert
wir sehen in der aktuellen situation wie
gut unser integriertes
hilfeleistungssystem aus feuerwehr
gefahrenabwehr katastrophenschutz und
zivilschutz ist in der veränderten
sicherheitslage sehen wir aber doch dass
der zivilschutz gestärkt werden muss und
daher meine frage an sie frau
bundesministerin was denn das
innenministerium jetzt auf die
veränderte sicherheitslage plant zum
schutz der kritischen infrastruktur zur
stärkung des zivilschutzes in der
klassischen und in der digitalen art und
wie auch die materiellen mittel dafür
aussehen im haushalt 22 und das
nachhaltig zu stärken um hier unser
gutes system noch besser aufzustellen
ganz herzlichen dank für ihre frage wir
haben in der tat im haushalt allein 100
stellen ins bbk zusätzlich gegeben um
die katastrophe schutz hilfe und den
bevölkerungsschutz zu verstärken das ist
sicherlich ein gutes signal dafür darf
ich mich bei der koalition auch noch mal
herzlich bedanken im namen der
bundesregierung das ist ein guter punkt
wir haben natürlich in allen anderen
bereichen auch jetzt verstärkt wir haben
verstärkt gerade thw die wir im einsatz
haben in den letzten jahren wurden dort
die haushaltsmittel sehr nach oben
gefahren was sehr wichtig jetzt ist weil
thw in zusammenarbeit wie sie es genannt
haben mit feuerwehr vor ort jetzt auch
bei der bei dem aufbau von
flüchtlingsunterkünften mit dabei ist
und dort wertvolle arbeit jetzt leistet
der zivilschutz ist etwas was wir uns
noch mal sehr genau jetzt angucken
müssen wie wir dort für die zukunft
verstärken und sie haben einen dritten
bereich angesprochen das ist der der
cyber sicherheit und der schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur vor solchen
übergriffen das haben wir extrem im
fokus sind dort sehr unterwegs auch alle
die die kritische infrastruktur
betreiben frühzeitig auch gewarnt worden
eine vorausschau verehrte zuschauer wäre
ihm eine die befragung der ministerin
läuft warten wir auf die
bundespressekonferenz auf den termin von
christian lindner denn das
bundeskabinett hat heute den
bundeshaushalt für
2022 gebilligt das wollen wir ihnen
gleich live zeigen wie befragung
übrigens können sie dann auch online
weiter verfolgen aber bis es in der
bundespressekonferenz los reden hören
wir noch mal weiter hier in den täter zu
geben soll das soll im juni an den start
gehen das ist eine wunderbare
kooperation ich glaube dass wir
gemeinsam aus bundesländern und bunt da
sehr sehr stark sein können und für den
bevölkerungsschutz viel gemeinsam
erreichen können vielen dank auch für
diese unterstützung
zuletzt habe ich dazu eine weitere
nachfrage zu diesem themenbereich aus
der sie selbst auffälligen bitte
ja vielen dank frau ministerin
ich glaube wir nehmen alle zur kenntnis
dass das land berlin moment die
hauptlast der aufnahme der geflüchteten
aus der ukraine hier in deutschland zu
leisten hat wir wissen den polen wird
eine ganz andere
aufnahme noch betrieben auch da glaube
ich gebührt unser aller dank denen die
das dort tun ich finde von hier aus
sollte ein klares signal ausgehen an die
vielen ehrenamtlichen
auch an die hilfsorganisation aber auch
an die verantwortlichen land berlin dass
sie das was sie jetzt gerade hier
eigentlich für das gesamte land tun dass
wir das wertschätzen und dass das einen
dicken applaus auch verdient hat
ich frage sie aber auch als
verantwortliche innenministerin ist ihre
auffassung dass der bund in den letzten
tagen und ja seit ausbruch des krieges
in der frucht bewegung ausreichend getan
hat um dem land berlin da auch zur seite
zu stehen wir haben zahlen von über
10.000 geflüchteten unterschrieben
status wir wissen dass die täglich nach
berlin kommen entweder weiter reisen
oder hier privat unterkommen oder
untergebracht werden müssen und mein
eindruck ist dass der bund da etwas
zögerlich ist im land berlin auch
tatsächlich unter die arme zu greifen
meine frage wäre wann denn tatsächlich
begonnen wurde so wie sie es gesagt
haben die verteilung auch die
verbindlichen nach königsteiner
schlüssel herkules zu nehmen und wie sie
ich komme zum schluss sie an zu spüren
bekommen die sie tatsächlich gedenken
mit welchen ressourcen das land berlin
als tor zu deutschland und als tor zum
osten an der richtung auch zu
unterstützen vielen dank weil sie gerne
einmal darauf hin dass das bei
nachfragen so ist das dafür 30 sekunden
zur verfügung stehen das ist unsere
gemeinsame verabredung nicht meine
besondere strenge heute so professor
bitte herzlichen dank für die frage und
ich schließe mich dem dank nicht nur an
die stadt berlin an auch an hamburg an
bremen an münchen weil es sind die
metropol städte die jetzt unglaubliches
geleistet haben und ich schliesse mich
mit ihrem dank an die ehrenamtlichen
helferinnen und helfer und derer die
dort gerade wirklich extrem viel stimmen
für uns alle ausdrücklich an das was wir
von anfang an getan haben ist dass wir
in zusammenarbeit mit den ländern sofort
nach ausbruch der furchtbaren krise des
krieges in der ukraine in die verteilung
gegangen sind das heißt ab dem 24
wir haben busse umgeleitet tag für tag
gemeinsam mit der bahn es gibt auch eine
arbeitsgruppe in der auch das land
berlin vertreten ist gemeinsam mit dem
bundesamt für güterverkehr
dort haben wir von anfang an verteilt
eine verteilung nach dem königsteiner
schlüssel war bis zum letzten wochenende
nicht nötig seit dem letzten wochenende
ist es nötig und nun machen wir das auch
der kollege curio hat das wort die
nächste frage
frau ministerin der vorsitzende
gewerkschaft der bundespolizei tigers
befürchtete sicherheitsrisiken wenn 40
prozent der ankommenden unkontrolliert
bleiben und wirft ihnen voraus wir dann
von 2015 nichts gelernt zu haben wenn
nicht ukraine hier ohne
identitätsfeststellung unkontrolliert
reinkommen am berliner hauptbahnhof sagt
ein bundespolizeibeamte reiste halbe
balkan ein unter 160 ukraine
flüchtlingen bayerischen verlassen waren
130 aus algerien marokko unter hunderten
garmisch partenkirchen 90 aus asien und
afrika angeblich studenten die aber
weder ukrainisch russisch noch englisch
sprechen diese leute brauchen jetzt hier
sicher keine aufnahme sie können in der
heimatland wir wollen kein missbrauch
unserer großen deutschen
hilfsbereitschaft wir wollen nicht die
selbe kontroll verweigerung wie 2015
sonst bleibt deutschland wieder
sperrangelweit offen für alle arten
unerwünschter trittbrettfahrer was
antworten sie herrn takats und warum
überlasten sie mit ihrer unspezifischen
aufnahme auch von nicht ukrainern die
ohne not nach hause können mutwillig die
aufnahmekapazitäten für die wirklich
bedürftigen
herr abgeordneter ich trage gerne zur
sachlichkeit der debatte bei
wir haben eine sehr veränderte situation
das hatte ich eingangs in bei meiner
bemerkungen auch schon gesagt zu 2015
die meisten allermeisten menschen reisen
mit biometrischen pass visafrei in unser
land ein die die sie angesprochen haben
sind sechs prozent der einreisenden und
ich hatte es auch eingangs gesagt
bundespolizei registriert dort und
deswegen gibt es auch keinen grund das
so aufzubauschen als sei das an diesem
problem
herr kuhn ist meine nachfrage bitte hin
nach eigener aussage der bundespolizei
also werden 40 prozent unkontrolliert
gelassen wir können nicht wollen dass
ich da wieder ein heer von abzockern
einmischt die ukraine ist kein land
afrikanischer austauschstudenten je mehr
unberechtigte kommen umso weniger
kapazitäten haben wir doch für die
wirklich hilfsbedürftigen wir haben
schon hunderttausende ausreisepflicht
die asylbewerber jetzt auch mal platz
für echte flüchtlinge waren sorgen sie
endlich dafür dass das heer der
ausreisepflichtigen außer landes kommt
so dass man denen jetzt wirklich
hilfsbedürftigen besser helfen kann
aus meiner sicht würde zunächst helfen
wenn sie nicht den sprachgebrauch
verwenden würden den sie verwenden nicht
nein das würde ihnen glaube ich helfen
weil es um die integration jetzt und der
aufnahme es geht der aufnahme um
menschen die von krieg fliehen aus krieg
in europa
und ich sage es ihnen noch mal
diejenigen die sie angesprochen haben
die sie aus meiner sicht etwas
sachlicher titulieren sollten sind sechs
prozent die bundespolizei macht einen
großartigen job ich empfehle ihnen gehen
sie mal einen bahnhof schauen sich an
was die bundespolizei dort
herausragendes leistet mein dank gilt
der bundespolizei
und mit der entega bin ich auch im engen
austausch
frau pollert hat eine weitere nachfrage
zum gleichen thema
ja ganz herzlichen dank frau präsidentin
liebe kollegin kollegin liebe
kolleginnen sehr geehrte frau ministerin
wir möchten ich möchte mich erst mal
ganz herzlich auch im namen meiner
fraktion bei ihnen bedanken ich glaube
es ist ein novum gewesen
dass innerhalb kürzester zeit zum ersten
mal nach 20 jahren die richtlinie
aktiviert wurde zum vorübergehenden
schutz und in diesem sinne geht jetzt
auch meine frage weil natürlich mit der
aktivierung der richtlinie jetzt die
solidaritäts plattform auch auf den weg
gebracht wurde sie werden ja auch
nochmal mit ihren europäischen
kolleginnen in den austausch gehen wie
wird ihr vorschlag seien für die
verteilung innerhalb europas weil wir
können ja von einer dynamischen lage
ausgehen danke
herr kurios sie haben wahrscheinlich vor
leidenschaft vergessen ihre maske wieder
aufzusetzen das machen sie sicher gern
dankeschön
frauenfrage abgeordnete poller wir
werden sie haben das richtig
angesprochen wir haben eine historisches
momentum das wir erreicht haben
einstimmig innerhalb der europäischen
union mit allen staaten diesen
vorübergehenden schutz in gang gesetzt
zu haben nämlich für kriegs geflüchtete
das ist das entscheidende
und keiner von uns hätte ja je für
möglich gehalten dass krieg mitten in
europa und so unmittelbar tatsächlicher
heilt wir werden jetzt wie sie es
angesprochen haben auf der europäischen
ebene in ein verteilsystem gehen müssen
und es gibt auch großartige angebote ich
will es einfach mal benennen die schweiz
hat beispielsweise jetzt angeboten
40.000 geflüchtete aufzunehmen und
möchte mit uns in kooperation
nachzutreten ich habe heute gehört dass
norwegen ein ähnliches angebot gemacht
hat und das muss jetzt auf der
europäischen ebene zusammen gefunden um
die das bundeskabinett hat heute den
haushalt 2022 gebilligt und auch das 100
milliarden euro paket sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr auf den weg gebracht dazu
gibt es die pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesfinanzminister und wir hören mal
rein
so die nächste frage kommt von herrn
hartmann die angemeldete frage
danke frau präsidentin sehr geehrte frau
ministerin daran direkt auch anknüpfen
noch mal herzlichen dank für ihre
initiativen die sie sofort mit der
amtsübernahme begonnen haben als sie in
europa amtskolleginnen und kollegen
besucht haben und sofort das thema
migration lange vor dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf die
ukraine durch putin zum thema und
schwerpunkt gemacht haben die auch
ermöglicht haben das setzt der
temporären schutz gewährt wird sie haben
auf der einen seite darauf hingewiesen
dass es um einen freiwilligen und
solidaritäts verteilen mechanismus geht
könnten sie bitte nennen sie noch einmal
einen ordnenden your tierart die in den
letzten wochen mehrfach getagt haben die
nächsten schritte auch auf europäischer
ebene zeitlich einzuordnen plus auch die
hilfestellung die stichwort katastrophen
schutzmechanismus für die direkten
anrainer staaten ukraine polen stand
heute über 1,8 millionen menschen die
aufgenommen worden sind dort im
europäischer akt der solidarität
begonnen worden sind und auch die
deutschen beiträge nochmal herausstellen
dass als nachfrage
ganz herzlichen dank herr abgeordneter
hartmann ich fange mal vorne an ja es
ist richtig ich habe die bemühungen in
europa verstärkt zu einem gemeinsamen
asylsystem auf europäischer ebene zu
kommen unabhängig von diesem
kriegsgeschehen ich halte das immer noch
für das sinnvollste und ich glaube dass
uns im moment die guten beratungen
miteinander auch da ein gutes stück
näher gebracht hat und auf diesem weg
auch erfolgreich sein wird da glaube ich
fest ich bin sicher dass das der
richtige weg für uns hier in deutschland
auch ist woran sieht man dass sie haben
es angesprochen einmal an der
solidarität jetzt mit dem in gang setzen
der solidaritäts richtlinie für
vorübergehenden schutz das heißt einen
direkten aufenthaltstitel wenn die
menschen aus der ukraine hierherkommen
gleichbedeutend mit einer
arbeitserlaubnis mehr integration
innerhalb der europäischen union geht
kaum ist wirklich etwas sehr sehr
positives und sie haben angesprochen die
europäische und kommission hat sehr früh
den katastrophenschutz mechanismus in
gang gesetzt auch das zeigt eine
solidarität innerhalb europas wo jetzt
sehr schnell die hilfsgesuche der
anrainerstaaten aber auch der ukraine
innerhalb der europäischen union
verteilt wird und da sind wir mit thw in
anderen hilfseinrichtungen schon sehr
sehr weit wir haben schon in der ukraine
verhindern aber auch vielen
anrainerstaaten vielen dank dafür
das war ein
zeitmanagement süßen er hat man hat noch
eine nachfrage
frau präsidentin genau an dem punkt noch
mal ankunft dass eine teil ist auf
europäischer ebene der andere teil ist
aber und da haben sie ja die länder auf
der j ebene direkt einbezogen landes
innenministers das stichwort auch ein
freiwilliger beitrag der länder zum
beispiel über das freiwillige
verteilzentrum in der messe laatzen dies
ist ein beitrag des landes niedersachsen
die ganz pragmatisch wie man das im
norden kennt angepackt haben und
angeboten haben zur entlastung
beizutragen an anderer stelle ist auch
von der großen aufnahmebereitschaft und
kapazität in anderen ländern gesprochen
worden in den bundesländern können sie
darlegen wie die verteil und hab
strukturen der länder zur ergänzung in
welchen zeit haben die aufgezogen worden
sind und welche möglichkeiten dann noch
bestehen in der perspektive stichwort
königssteiner schlüssel und easy
verteilung über dampf unterstützen dass
ich jetzt schon gute tat liegt daran
dass diese nachfragen nur 30 sekunden
dauern dürfen wir aber nicht 30 sekunden
einstellen dürfen das heißt sie müssen
das abrechnen das gilt natürlich für
alle genau frau ministerin ganz
herzlichen dank herr hartmann ich will
das noch mal betonen und mich bei allen
bundes dann bedanken wie gut die
kooperation in diesen ersten 14 tagen
sind sie jetzt fast
funktioniert hat darf mich da
ausdrücklich für bedanken dass gerade
hannover also niedersachsen sehr schnell
ein verteilzentrum noch mal aufgebaut
hat was uns sehr weitergeholfen hat auch
in der frage die lasten die zweifelsohne
gerade berlin zu tragen hatte und hat
dort auch hin zu entlasten das war
großartig das hat bis zum letzten
wochenende sehr gut funktioniert dann
mussten wir aber feststellen und das war
auch der wunsch der länder dass nach dem
königsteiner schlüssel jetzt verteilt
wird das machen wir ab dieser woche das
ist auch für uns in ordnung über die
registrierung bei den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen wird auch im
system easy registrierte gysi hat eine
eigene verteilen mechanismus der nach
dem königsteiner schlüssel richtet
vielen dank
genau wir haben jetzt mehrere nachfragen
eine lasse ich zu und zwar der
reihenfolge nach das heißt wenn sie noch
weitere nachfragen haben wollen dann
müssen sie sich immer relativ schnell
melden damit wir das hier gut managen
können in diesen zeiten und der erste
war der kollege filmen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin sie erwähnte
neben die wichtigkeit des gemeinsamen
europäischen vorgehens in asylfragen nun
hatten wir ja vor einiger zeit die
situation des an der polnischen grenze
der diktator aus weißrussland eine menge
migranten hat aufmarschieren lassen es
war eine gemeinsame europäische linie
die nicht nach europa zu lassen können
sie uns denn sagen wo diese migranten
jetzt sind und können sie ausschließen
dass sie nicht vielleicht die situation
in der ukraine ausnutzen um als
trittbrettfahrer nun doch zu uns zu
kommen herr abgeordneter ich kann ihnen
so viel sagen wie ich vorhin schon
beantwortet haben dass wir alle
drittstaatler besonders kontrollieren
das macht die bundespolizei in
hervorragender art und weise und ich
kann ihnen die frage ob die geflüchteten
aus belarus weitergeleitet worden sind
im moment nur mit erkenntnissen die die
bundespolizei hat so beantworten dass es
kein durchleiten seitens belarus aktiv
gibt im moment das ist eine
momentaufnahme kann man nie ausschließen
aber auch das haben wir im blick
danke liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie
sehen die besetzung hat wechselt das
wird heute noch mehrfach so erfolgen und
ich werde weiter so verfahren wie die
kollegin göring eckardt das jetzt hier
eingeführt hat für diese woche das wort
zur nächsten frage hat die kollegin
klara dünger
vielen dank frau präsidentin
vielen dank frau ministerin
mehrere stimmen in der zivilgesellschaft
haben sich bereits dafür ausgesprochen
dass kriegsdienstverweigerer aus
russland asyl gewährt asyl zu gewähren
ist und nach geltendem asylrecht in
deutschland hätten diese gruppe auch in
der regel einen anspruch auf einen
flüchtlingsstatus hier ist die
bundesregierung denn bereit vielleicht
auch in absprache mit anderen eu staaten
ein klares signal an die satire und der
satyr in zu senden dass sie hier in
deutschland einen schutzstatus bekommen
können wenn sie sich dem
völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg entziehen wir beraten das
in der tat frau abgeordnete wie gesagt
haben auf der europäischen ebene ich
möchte diese beratung auch nicht vorweg
greifen weil ich glaube es ist klug ein
einheitliches abgestimmtes verfahren
gerade darüber zu haben weil das ja
nicht ganz und empfindlich ist und in
gewisser weise auch in den krieg mit
eingreift
wozu noch trocken vielen dank aus
unserer sicht wäre die einreise dass
insbesondere ein problem für diese
personengruppe wie wehrt sich die
bundesregierung wie werden sie sich
dafür einsetzen dass ist sichere
fluchtwege für diese personengruppe
geben wird also soweit ich weiß ist es
kein problem dafür auch auszureisen ich
war an der polnisch ukrainischen grenze
und habe dort nicht berichtet bekommen
und auch nicht gesehen dass solche
menschen abgewiesen würden über den
flucht korridor
die kolleginnen cordes stellt noch eine
nachfrage
wie vielen dank frau ministerin für die
ausführung nach all dem was wir gerade
gehört haben sehen wir es ja ein sehr
komplexes bild was daran orientiert und
sehr komplexe herausforderung und
deshalb vielleicht die bitte nach
bundeseinheitlicher oder mehr steuerung
vom bund und dazu natürlich auch die
frage ist das angebracht also gibt es
einen sogenannten flüchtlings gipfel
wird es den geben
fragte dort ordnete kaddor dankeschön
für ihre frage die steuerung machen wir
sehr stark von anfang an ich sage es
nochmal wir haben mit den ländern
gemeinsam in dieser arbeitsgruppe mit
dem brg mit dem verkehrsministerium weil
es natürlich sinn macht gerade überzüge
bus verteilung auch das
verkehrsministerium mit einzubinden da
bin ich meinem kollegen volker wissing
auch sehr dankbar für die enge
kooperation die wir tag für tag haben
auch am wochenende wenn ich das einmal
sagen darf sehr intensiv war und wir
werden diese woche den königsteiner
schlüssel an wenn also noch stärker
steuern ich hatte letzte woche eine gute
runde mit den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden und es wird sicherlich
einen adäquaten austausch mit den
kommunalen spitzenverbänden mit den
ländern und dem bund geben
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
kunstdieb cool
ja vielen dank liebe frau
bundesministerin wir haben eine
situation in der sich die schlimmste
flüchtlingskrise in europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
darstellt und ich glaube es ist gut dass
wir so viel hilfsbereitschaft und auch
soviel unbürokratische hilfe durch die
nachbarstaaten der ukraine gesehen haben
und auch dem bundesinnenministerium
ausdrücklich dankeschön dafür dass diese
sachen in deutschland möglich gemacht
worden sind ich mache mir aber ein
bisschen sorgen ob wirklich alle
staatlichen ebenen das
ausmaß dieser katastrophe schon
verstanden haben und deswegen ist meine
frage wie wir die verschiedenen
staatlichen ebenen jetzt noch besser
darüber informieren können was ihre
rolle ist und deswegen würde mich genau
interessieren was ist jetzt in dieser
konkreten konstellation die rolle des
bundes was machen die länder was machen
die kommunen und wie stellen wir sicher
dass die verschiedenen staatlichen
ebenen auch erfahren was ihre rolle ist
und dass die kommunikation zwischen den
akteuren sichergestellt wird ganz
herzlichen dank herr coole für ihre
frage wir haben ein sehr enges netzwerk
in der kooperation wir haben nahezu
einen täglichen austausch mit den
bundesländern wir haben einen intensiven
austausch auch mit den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden um zu schauen wäre es
jetzt für was zuständig wir haben zum
beispiel die situation wenn jetzt die
geflüchteten die ja einen sehr
unbürokratischen aufenthaltstitel
bekommen wenn sie leistungen haben
möchten müssen sie in einer
ausländerbehörde sich registrieren
lassen die registrierung die sie in der
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung gemacht haben
reicht dafür auch aus aber sie müssen
sich anmelden um ihre leistung zu
erhalten das ist jetzt eine kommunale
aufgabe um das mal ab zu schichten wer
für was im moment zuständig ist für die
unterbringung erstversorgung der
geflüchteten sind die bundesländer
zuständig aber wir helfen dort sehr
stark weil die registrierung
mittlerweile elektronisch sehr gut
funktioniert wir haben solche sogenannte
pick stationen wir nehmen zehn
fingerabdrücke alles wird registriert
das dauert ein bisschen deswegen helfen
wir dort mit mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern des bamf mit diesen geräten
und unterstützen die länder bei dieser
aufgabe wir helfen mit thw beim aufbau
auch von flüchtlingsunterkünften und wir
helfen sehr stark mit der bundespolizei
so dass wir miteinander sehr viel
steuern denn sie erlauben er wenig auch
noch ganz kurz dass wir jetzt auch auf
der europäischen ebene schon stärker
steuern weil ich seit dem letzten
wochenende und seit beginn der woche mit
volker wissing gemeinsam einen
ansprechpartner in polen hat womit wir
jetzt auch täglich absprachen über die
verteilung treffen
sie haben das wort zu einer nachfolge
ich bitte die folgende wie auch die
ministerin auf die verabredete zeit
jeweils 8 vielen dank frau präsidentin
liebe frau bundes innenministerin sie
haben dem königsteiner schlüssel erwähnt
es ist gut dass der jetzt in deutschland
anwendung findet er kann ja aber nur
angewandt werden soweit die personen
registriert sind und deswegen würde ich
sie bitten noch einmal ein wort zu sagen
zu der gruppe derjenigen die privat
untergekommen sind und die noch nicht
registriert sind wie viele sind das
ungefähr und wie kommen wir bei dieser
gruppe die privat untergekommen es jetzt
auch dazu dass die registriert werden
und dann verteilt werden also wir werden
jetzt auf jeden fall über diese
plattform die wir diese woche anbieten
an die geflüchteten die jetzt bei
verwandten freunden untergekommen sind
auf eigene faust hier eingereist sind
eben nicht über zuge gekommen sind wo
wir sie ja zumindest gezählt haben und
wissen wer quasi hier ist darüber werden
wir jetzt noch mal die informationen
versenden weil sie müssen ja auch
leistungen erhalten können sie wollen ja
auch arbeiten sie brauchen eine
arbeitserlaubnis das kann man alles bei
der ausländerbehörde erhalten und ich
glaube dass man über diese plattformen
die menschen gut erreichen kann
zu einer nachfolger der abgeordnete
teuer
frau ministerin und ich komme auf das
thema der aufgaben noch mal zurück ich
weiß nicht wann sie am hauptbahnhof
gewesen sind und sich die situation
angesehen haben
wer erfasst bei wem die geflüchteten
aufgenommen werden und wer das ist bei
wem die aufnahme stattgefunden hat damit
da kein schindluder getrieben wird also
zuerst mal wird erfasst bei quasi
grenzübertritt von polen nach
deutschland weil in die züge die
bundespolizei reingeht und sich alle
pässe zeigen lässt das passiert in der
regel frankfurt oder an den über grenzen
passiert ist und die erfassung in dem
system was ich eben genannt wird das
passiert in berlin wenn sie in die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen kommen mit
fingerabdruck system mit allem eine
ausnahme davon wenn ich ihnen das noch
mal sagen darf sind alle die ohne pass
kommen und auch und/oder drittstaatler
sind weil die von der bundespolizei in
den bearbeitungs straßen bereits in
frankfurt oder
aufgenommen werden in die systeme
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
alexander thrun
der frau ministerin fest ich will ihnen
die gelegenheit geben ihre aussage von
vorhin und auch jetzt so eben nochmals
zu überprüfen weil sie widerspricht den
darstellungen ihrer staatssekretärin
erst heute morgen im innenausschuss wir
registrieren und stellen auch personen
nicht durchgehend fest und das betrifft
auch nicht nur diejenigen die einen
biometrischen pass haben und damit
visafrei einreisen sondern auch bei
anderen personen wird nicht durchgehend
registriert und festgestellt deswegen
gebe ich ihnen die gelegenheit ist nun
mal dazu stellen wir wissen momentan
nicht wie viele personen aus der ukraine
nach deutschland eingereist sind und wo
sie sind das ist ganz anders
beispielsweise in polen polen hat eine
sehr genaue kenntnis landwehr und wie
viel bei ihnen angekommen sind und wo
ihre reiseziele sind was macht bohlen
besser als wir jetzt komm ich versuche
es ihn noch mal zu sagen leute peter
strohm ich versuch's nochmal zu erklären
da gibt es auch gar keinen widerspruch
glaube ich zwischen mir und dem
staatssekretär ich habe ja eben
erläutert dass unterschiedliche personen
mit unterschiedlichen schutzstatus
ankommen und anders registriert werden
haben gerade erläutert in frankfurt oder
geht die bundespolizei und die züge
seien lässt sich alle ausweise zeigen
die die keine haben oder die die
drittstaatler sind werden erfasst im
system das ist das eine so das andere
ist die menschen die mit biometrischen
pass aus einreisen und 90 tage visafrei
in deutschland bleiben können die haben
das recht sich frei zu bewegen die
werden wir und da bin ich sicher da wenn
sie mit mir einer meinung wenn die
weiterreise nach paris nach madrid auch
nicht daran hindern wollen sie werden
dort freunde bekannte angehörige treffen
jetzt zeige ich ihnen einmal den
unterschied zu holen und zu uns holen
macht hat eine grenze zur ukraine
dort stehen die menschen die von krieg
und flucht und vertreibung und vom
bombenhagel
betroffen sind schlange um ein zu reisen
in das land in der kälte und wollen sie
wirklich in deutschland die grenzen
wieder schließen und genau das gleiche
nochmal an der grenze von polen zu
deutschland machen wenn das so ist dann
sagen sie ist meine auffassung ist das
nicht
[Applaus]
da geht wohl in ihrem haus einiges
durcheinander weil nochmals die
darstellung ihrer staatssekretäre heute
morgen war unisono eine andere bitte
erkundigen sie sich bei ihnen und
deswegen die frage die grünen sind ja
auch unzufrieden und haben
beispielsweise einen flüchtlings gipfel
im kanzleramt gefordert halten sie das
auch für notwendig zur besseren
koordination muss die krise jetzt hier
chefsache werden
also da sie bislang noch keine einladung
dafür bekommen haben herum sehen sie
dass wir das sehr gelassen sehen ich
habe gesagt wird ein geeignetes format
geben auch noch mal öffentlich über das
was wir im arbeitsalltag jeden tag
miteinander besprechen sei es mit den
kommunalen spitzenvertretern oder mit
den ländern vertretern auch auflegen
werden ich glaube dass diese fragen auch
das erfassen und des verteilens
innerhalb deutschlands und vor allen
dingen ich will es noch mal sagen der
humanitären aufnahme insbesondere von
frauen mit kleinen kindern hier in
deutschland gewährleistet wird auch
gerade gute arbeit geleistet wird
noch mal kurz die erläuterung heute gilt
die praxis dass es noch eine nachfrage
eines weiteren oder einer weiteren
abgeordneten gibt der erste der sich
jetzt zu dieser frage gemeldet hat war
der kollege to me ich habe sie gesehen
aber wir haben noch chancen dass auch
sie nachher noch mit nachfragen zum zuge
kommen bitte wie lang frau präsidentin
frau ministerin den widerspruch ein
kollege throm zur canon vermeinte
zwischen ihren aussagen der straße das
konnte ich auch nicht feststellen
ich bin
aber auch bedienen der auffassung dass
es notwendig ist genau festzustellen wer
kommt im lande an denn nur dann wenn du
wissen wie viele kommen wer kommt ob das
vielleicht um die minderjährige sind
frauen die allein kommen oder familien
ältere nur dann kann man sinnvoll und
gerecht und fair teiler feststellen
welche bedürfnisse ergeben sich daraus
an kinderbetreuung betreuung von älteren
personen und dergleichen mehr und
deswegen hatte ich schon richtig dass
das ein möglichst genaues register
wichtig ist bin sehr froh dass sie schon
auf dagegen haben dass ein solches
regierungsbank erstellt wird auch die
polen und andere länder tun dass und nun
werde sicherlich auch sinnvoll hält wenn
diese geschieden 30 sekunden register
abgestimmt würden da ist meine frage an
sie gibt es einen abgleich zwischen
registern etwa in polen und deutschland
ich hätte mir was ich ihn zumindest
sagen kann und das ist ein echter
fortschritt wir haben wenn wir erfassen
über diese pigs station was ich vorhin
erklärt habe auch bei der erstaufnahme
der geflüchteten wir registrieren ja
schon obwohl sie in biometrischen pass
haben wir es gar nicht müssten wird ja
schon erfasst diese datenabgleich geht
beispielsweise mit eurodac also im
system bei uns im
ausländerzentralregister mit eurodac das
überhaupt kein problem übrigens auch mit
den daten der bundespolizei und dem
dampf das ist ein echter fortschritt
dass wir da schon so weit sind jetzt
geht es nur noch darum dass wir das auch
möglichst flächendeckend hinbekommen und
dafür leisten wir gerade sehr viel
unterstützung vielen dank
die nächste frage stellt die kolleginnen
kaum
den vielen dank frau präsidentin vielen
dank frau ministerin sie haben es vorhin
angesprochen ihren aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus begrüßen sehr dass sie
da der prävention auch ordentlich platz
einräumen vielen dank dafür
uns ist es besonders wichtig dass wir
entschlossen gegen antisemitismus gegen
rassismus gegen islamfeindlichkeit krieg
feindlichkeit und jede andere form von
gruppenbezogener menschenfeindlichkeit
streiten und an der stattliche frage was
möchten sie dafür tun in ihrem
aktionsplan fielen dann
ganz herzlichen dank frau abgeordnete
dass sie dieses so wichtige thema
ansprechen wir haben zwei oder drei
richtig große bereiche präventiven
ansatzes in dem aktionsplan vorgelegt
das eine ist dass wir programme auflegen
wollen wie wir diese gruppenbezogene
menschlich menschenfeindlichkeit
frühstmöglich bekämpfen können das
zweite ist ein medien
medienkompetenz vermittlung weil wir
zunehmend feststellen dass im internet
in den sozialen medien über rechte
medien falsch informiert wird und wir
müssen gerade junge leute stark machen
dabei medienkompetenz zu haben damit sie
diese nicht auf diese
verschwörungstheorien und rechtsextreme
theorien rein fallen das ist der zweite
bereich und der dritte bereich ist vor
allen dingen in der gesamtgesellschaft
präventiv an allen stellen wo es nötig
ist aber vor allen dingen aus unserem
haus heraus wir haben die heimat
abteilung dafür extra noch weiter
ausgebaut präventiv durch einzelne
projekte noch mal die menschen zu
stärken und resilient dafür übergriffe
von rechtsextremisten zu machen und auch
aussteigerprogramme zu stärken
sie haben das wort zur ersten ich dann
der bullige krämer
vielen dank frau präsidentin frau
ministerin ich hätte noch mal eine
nachfrage den sportbereich betreffend
wir haben uns im koalitionsvertrag ja
auch ein bundesprogramm gegen
rechtsextremismus und
menschenfeindlichkeit
vorgenommen welche schwerpunkte möchten
sie da gerne setzen und welchen zeitplan
haben sie sich dort vorgenommen
vielen dank herr abgeordneter für mich
ist es ein ganz wichtiger bereich dass
wir gerade den sport bei mir im haus ich
bin nach sportministerin gerade der
bereich integration durch sport sehr
viel mehr raum geben und haben dort auch
noch einmal mittel verstärkt jetzt
gerade auch in vorbereitung und
präventiven projekten auch zur
verhinderung von rechtsextremismus und
haben dort ein völlig neues konzept
aufgestellt und verstärkt das freut mich
sehr dass sie das gut zur kenntnis
nehmen wir wollen aber den sport
insgesamt sehr stark stärken wir haben
jetzt auch noch mal im neuen haushalt
mehr mittel drin und ich freue mich auch
dass wir im nächsten jahr die
special olympics world games hier in
deutschland haben und werden dort auch
sehr viel gelder verstärken um das auch
da noch mal sehr praktisch zu
unterstützen vielen dank
die nächste frage stellt der abgeordnete
martin has
broken destiny
pressekonferenz zum wiederholten mal den
rechtsextremismus als größte
sicherheitsgefahren umland dargestellt
die objektive zahlen lage spricht aber
eine andere sprache 454 islamistische
gefährder denen stehen 76
rechtsextremistische gegenüber der
generalbundesanwalt hat seit 2009 10
1700 islamistische terror verfahren
eingeleitet dem gegenüber stehen 40
terror verfahren gegen rechtsextremisten
und bei dem verhinderten islamistischen
anschlag in köln hätten bis zu 13.500
tote und noch mal so viele verletzte
also in summe 27.000 opfer beklagen
werden müssen wenn er oben gesetzt
worden wäre sind sie angesichts dieser
klaren zahlen bereit ihre priorität in
der extremismusbekämpfung zu korrigieren
insofern der objektiven zahlen lage
anzupassen und zukünftig den
islamistischen terror als größte
sicherheitsgefahr klar zu benennen und
zu bekämpfen herr abgeordneter ich sage
es nochmal ich habe von meiner ersten
rede schon gesagt selbstverständlich
bekämpft mein haus alle formen von
extremismus sei es linksextremismus
islamistische terrorismus oder
rechtsextremismus im moment und dann
nehmen sie immer nur die zahlen die
ihnen gerade passen in die argumentation
ist es leider so dass der
rechtsextremismus die größte bedrohung
für die demokratische grundordnung in
der bundesrepublik darstellt
und damit bin ich auch nicht alleine sie
können sich gerne die pressekonferenz
von gestern noch mal angucken weil
sowohl der chef des bundes
verfassungsschutz in deutschland als
auch der bka-präsident gestern
eindeutig dargelegt haben dass die
höchsten zahlen im moment im bereich
phänomen bereich rechts sind
ja gut dass ich sie ansprechen der
präsident des bundesamts für
verfassungsschutz hat gestern einen der
uns das nur eine gefahrenlage zahlen der
amadeu-antonio-stiftung land oder
ausgeführt das sind ja alles eindeutig
eine linkslastige stiftung und halten
sie es als innenministerin tatsächlich
für zielführend sich bei der
extremismusbekämpfung auch spekulative
zahlen von eindeutig nicht objektiven
externen organisationen zu stützen
anstatt auf die validen zahlen des bka
die wesentlich niedriger liegen und
können sie nachvollziehen die irritation
die ein solches vorgehen nicht nur
mitarbeiter der sicherheitsbehörden
erzeugt sondern auch bei einer vielzahl
der bildung
ich wiederhole meine antwort noch mal
ziehen sie nicht einzelne zahlen raus um
sie für ihre argumentation zu
missbrauchen der präsident des
bundesamts für verfassungsschutzes hat
gestern in seiner ersten bemerkung die
zahlen aus der polizeilichen
kriminalitätsstatistik
zitiert und die sind aus meiner sicht
nicht fehleranfällig und da sind die
meisten nun mal im bereich des
rechtsextremismus was sie angesprochen
haben ist die zahl der gewalttaten gegen
menschen und er hat deshalb die antonio
studio herangezogen weil oft nicht
erfasst wird bei straftaten weil es
nämlich so ist ich bin weiß nicht ob sie
auch jurist sind
sie sind polizist dann wissen sie das
weil die zahlen erfassung bei einer
verurteilt verurteilung sich in der
regel danach bemisst welches nach
welchem schwersten delikte verurteilt
wurde und wenn ich beispielsweise einen
totschlag habe dann taucht nur der
totschlag in der erfassung der statistik
auf aber nicht dass auch dort
rechtsextremismus war das macht die
antonio amodeo stiftung anders und
deswegen hat er diese zahlen benutzt
zu einer nachfrage hat die abgeordnete
renate
frau präsidentin frau ministerin ich
hätte eine nachfrage zum aktionsplan
unter dem punkt netzwerke zerschlagen
sprechen sie dort auch die rolle von
finanzmitteln in der extremen rechten an
zum beispiel durch nazi
rockveranstaltung was mir fehlt ist dass
man eben auch steuerhinterziehung zum
thema machen muss und die frage
geldwäsche durch einnahmen aus dem
bereich der organisierten kriminalität
ich glaube sogar dass es bei dem was wir
in extrem rechten beobachten derzeit bis
in den bereich der terrorfinanzierung
geht meine frage wie arbeiten sie an der
stelle mit justiz und zum beispiel zeug
riemann am zusammen und was soll dort
verändert werden frau abgeordnete renner
ich bin ihnen außer uns dankbar dass es
ansprechen weil selbstverständlich
werden wir über den aktionsplan hinaus
den rechtsextremismus ganzheitlich
bekämpfen die das was gestern vorgelegt
wurde das ausdrücklich ein aktionsplan
aus dem hause des
bundesinnenministeriums und habe keine
ressortübergreifenden
schnittmengen deswegen haben wir es so
gefasst wie es gefasst haben wo wir
selber tätig sein können
selbstverständlich werde ich gemeinsam
mit dem bundesfinanzminister und dem
bundesjustizminister auch im bereich der
organisierten kriminalität geldwäsche
und andere dinge dort sehr eng
abgestimmt vorgehen
die nächste frage stellt elisabeth
kaiser
ja ich möchte das gerne noch erweitern
wir haben noch weitere wichtige vorhaben
unserer koalition und zwar dass
demokratie fördergesetz und wir alle
wissen dass die zivilgesellschaft eine
tragende säule ist für unsere demokratie
sie ist eine säule auch der kommune und
wir müssen ihnen das rückgrat stärken
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass das
gesetz jetzt auf den weg kommen soll und
nun ist die frage wie es konkret
ausgestaltet wird es gibt ein
diskussionspapier was schon an die
gesellschaft herangegangen ist zur
stellungnahme und da soll ein rahmen
gesetzt werden um eben auch die
zivilgesellschaft zu unterstützen da
frage ich mich was sollen die
schwerpunkte seien dieses rahmens gerade
auch mit ihnen mit dem blick auf die
förderstrukturen ausstieg software
beratung aber auch gerade mobile
beratung wie soll das aussehen und auch
mit blick auf die zwei federführung
ihres hauses und aber auch des hauses
davon der ministerin der wird nie wird
dann die konkrete ausfertigung aussehen
also wer übernimmt die verantwortung
vielen dank frau ordnete kaiser ein sehr
wichtiges projekt auch da bin ich ihnen
dankbar dass die sun spricht nämlich
auch nicht bestandteil des aktionsplanes
bewusst nicht weil in der tat das unter
der federführung des bmj jv ist also das
heißt vor einem spiegel wird dort die
federführung haben wir machen aber eine
gemeinsame vorbereitung gemeinsame
federführung in der erarbeitung aber sie
wird die technische federführung haben
das heißt die gesetzesvorhaben auch auf
den weg bringen ich bin mir da auch sehr
dankbar wir sind in sehr engen austausch
es geht ja vor allen dingen bei dem
demokratie fördergesetz etwas ganz
wesentliches nämlich um die verstetigte
finanzielle unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft und das steht
natürlich dort auch hauptsächlich im
fokus neben dem was sie alles
angesprochen haben an präventiven
frühzeitigen maßnahmen
aussteigerprogramm das erarbeiten wir
gerade mit der zivilgesellschaft und wir
wollen gerne im zeitplan bleiben so dass
wir ende des jahres dieses gesetz dann
gemeinsam ins kabinett bringen vielen
dank
bevor sie ihren nachfrage stellen der
hinweis herr brandner leiterin andere
kollege schneller so sie haben das wort
zur nachfrage
danke dir ausführungen ich würde noch
interessieren als nachfrage was konkret
im bereich politische bildung auch
vorgesehen ist soll das dort auch eine
rolle mitspielen und demokratie
fördergesetz da würde ich mir gerne
nochmal ausführungen bieten vielen dank
ganz herzlichen dank vom kaiser das
haben wir vor allen dingen gestern in
dem aktionsplan schon mit aufgenommen
herr krüger als leiter der
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
war gestern dabei bei der
pressekonferenz ich habe noch nicht die
gelegenheit gehabt ihm dafür zu danken
und ihnen auch zu erwähnen ebenso wie
dem bka präsidenten und dem bundes von
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten wir wollen
dort das was ich vorhin gesagt habe vor
allen dingen stärken frühzeitige
kompetenz stärkung junger leute um damit
auch umgehen zu können resilienz zu sein
gegen die ansprache von
rechtsextremisten wir wollen
medienkompetenz dort vermitteln weil das
thema der beeinflussung durch rechte
medien ein sehr aktuelles ist und was
sich vor allen dingen auch bei den hier
ist noch mal sagen ja noch immer
stattfindenden corona protesten auch
sehr manifestiert in der frage wie
nutzen rechtsextreme dass dort aus mit
welchen medien arbeiten sie dort
zusammen und da wollen wir im
politischen bildungsbereich ganz viel
verstärken um auch dort eine andere
kompetenzvermittlung zu erteilen vielen
dank herr hoffmann
frau vize-präsidentin ich möchte zahlen
die ich hier im plenum schon erwähnt
worden sind noch ergänzen heute
vormittag mussten wir den bericht des
präsidenten des verfassungsschutzes im
innenausschuss zur kenntnis nehmen über
den verdachtsfall afd und das urteil des
vg köln und das wurde auf eine über 1000
seitiges gutachten verwiesen dass er
eine vielzahl von entgleisungen
vorwürfen und nachweisen aufführt wo der
beweis angetreten wird dass man nicht
auf dem boden der verfassung steht und
eben auch die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung feindlich gegenübersteht
dass die afg betrifft sie haben neben
aktionsplan die entfernung von
rechtsextremisten aus den kreisen der
sicherheitsbehörden aus den kreisen des
öffentlichen dienstes zu einem der
schwerpunkte erhoben das ist ein
zentraler punkt den sie erwähnt haben
oder doch nur boten 30 sekunden mit
könnten sie diese möglichkeiten des
disziplinar echtes unter ansätze des bmi
noch einmal darlegen ja ganz herzlichen
dank herr hartmann es ist ein ganz
wichtiger bereich weil diejenigen die
den staat vertreten müssen diejenigen
sein die nicht nur sich auf dem boden
des grundgesetzes bewegen sondern eine
besondere vorbildfunktion haben das will
ich noch mal heraus heben umso wichtiger
ist es dass wir extremisten
verfassungsfeinde aus dem öffentlichen
dienst auch schnell entfernen können wir
wollen insbesondere im disziplinarrecht
und wahrscheinlich auch im beamtenrecht
insoweit ändern dass beispielsweise was
mich schon seit langem umtreibt ist dass
wir eine möglichkeit schaffen die
beweislast umzukehren das heißt wenn
tatsachen vorliegen dass dann derjenige
auch beweisen muss dass es eben nicht so
ist anstelle dass der staat immer
nachweisen muss sehr kompliziert dass
eben andere gründe dafür vorliegen dass
er nicht verfassungstreue ist das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt der zweite
wichtige punkt ist aus meiner sicht dass
es keinen grund dafür gibt dass jemand
der nur sich im in einem zeit darf ich
noch ganz
anständig wohl aus versehen um sie zum
ende zu ich versuche es ganz schnell zu
beenden dass diejenigen die ihr
beamtenverhältnis ruhen lassen dass dort
die anforderungen an denjenigen geringer
sind als wenn er sich in der pension
befindet auch das ist etwas was ich
gerne ändern möchte was ich nicht in
ordnung finde
die nächste vorgestellt die kollegen
kümmern
vielen dank dass ich jetzt auch noch
eine zweite frage stellen darf es haben
jetzt viele darüber gesprochen dass hier
alle menschen aufgenommen werden und
auch alle tritt starterinnen also ich
möchte dem vehement noch einmal
widersprechen ich begrüße das natürlich
und wir begrüßen das natürlich das jetzt
hier viele menschen aufgenommen werden
denn das zeigt doch aus meiner sicht wie
eine solidarische asylpolitik
funktionieren kann und das ist gut so
und das begrüßen wir natürlich auch ich
stelle mir dennoch die frage warum
werden nicht alle geflüchteten so
solidarisch aufgenommen hier in
deutschland warum wir das beispiel
beispielsweise nicht allen geflüchteten
ermöglicht bei verwandten und bekannten
unterzukommen wenn sie die möglichkeit
dazu haben warum werden andere
asylsuchende vielmehr weiterhin
gezwungen in menschenunwürdigen
erstaufnahme anlagern sogenannten anker
zentren untergebracht zu werden
ist ihr haus da bereit generell darüber
nachzudenken denken das zu ändern oder
wie sieht der plan diesbezüglich bei
hinaus vielen dank für abgeordnete für
die frage die sie mir gestellt haben sie
haben ja gesehen dass wir umfangreiche
vorhaben im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben für eine
menschenwürdige aufnahme von
asylbewerberinnen asylbewerbern in
deutschland da wird es verbesserungen
geben ich möchte aber im übrigen darauf
nochmal verweisen wenn sie ansprechen
das asylstatus etwas ist was möglichst
auch europaweit einheitlich geregelt
werden sollte auch da kämpfen wir für
bessere standards in vielen ländern
deswegen meine starken bemühungen
insbesondere in europa auch für ein
europäisches asylsystem zu kämpfen sie
um das wozu nachfrage ich hätte dann
noch eine nachfrage
einige hatten es auch gerade
angesprochen die polnische russische
grenze wie können sie rechtfertigen dass
an der grenze an der polnischen
außengrenze auf der einen seite menschen
illegal gepusht weg werden was ganz
klaren völkerrechtswidrig verstoß ist
und auf der anderen seite eben menschen
offen mit offenen armen aufgenommen
werden wie wie können sie diesen
unterschied erklären und sollten sich
alle menschen mit dem mit dem gleichen
rechten hier in der eu aufgenommen
werden ich glaube nicht dass ich mich
dazu erklären muss weil ich eine der
wenigen die im namen der bundesregierung
in brüssel gesagt habe das ist ein die
einhaltung von menschenrechtsstandards
immer an den grenzen der eu geben muss
zu einer nachfolger der kollege der
frist das gut
die bundesregierung hat 38 beauftragte
berufen wir befinden uns wie konnte es
dann den coole gesagt hat in der
schlimmsten flüchtlingskrise europa seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg wir müssen wenn
wir den migrationsforscher im glauben
damit rechnen dass auch weit über eine
million menschen nach deutschland kommen
können dass eine nationale
kraftanstrengung
wie kann es sein in einer solchen
situation dass es in der bundesregierung
kein flüchtlings koordinator gibt keinen
nationalen krisenstab denn der lage ist
politisch diese herausforderungen zu
bewältigen so wie es angela merkel
damals auch mit dem flüchtlingslager
gemacht hat der im bundeskanzleramt
angesiedelt worden ist
de vries ich darf mich ganz herzlich ein
abgeordneter für die frage bedanken wir
haben eine ähnliche krisen struktur die
unter leitung von staatssekretär engelke
stattfindet das war damals die kollegin
hamann insofern staatssekretärin ist es
eine ähnliche struktur in der krisen
struktur das scheinen sie zu begrüßen
dafür darf ich mich ganz herzlich
bedanken
und ansonsten haben wir wie ich finde
eine sehr gute aufstellung weil wir
jetzt eine sehr gute zusammenarbeit mit
den ländern und kommunen haben um diese
zeit krieg in europa gut zu bewältigen
danke frau präsidentin sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin ich habe eine frage zum
themenkomplex telegramm telegramm war ja
und ist immer noch in teil der
öffentlichen debatten wir haben an
verschiedenen stellen viel
problematisches bei telegramm gesehen
den letzten tagen auch einige positive
seiten und sieht das telegramm netz hat
schattenseiten und licht manchmal wird
es benutzt für menschen die vertraulich
kommunizieren müssen weil sie in regime
leben in denen sie unterdrückt werden
und nur dort verschlüsselt und sicher
kommunizieren können an anderen stellen
ist es teilweise in öffentlichen
bereichen
dave zur verbreitung von von hass taten
von straftaten benutzt sie haben in der
vergangenheit versucht telegramm zu
kontaktieren zusammen mit dem
justizministerium marco buschmann und
sie haben gemeinsam auch öffentlich
kommuniziert in der hinsicht und das ist
ihnen gelungen inzwischen sind sechs und
64 kanäle zb von attila hildmann
gelöscht worden können sie uns bitte mal
informieren wie dort die kommunikation
derzeit auch noch weiter lauf was da
geschehen ist und wie sie da in kontakt
kommen sind damit wir da mal weiter
informiert werden vielen dank herr
abgeordnete verliehen wir haben in der
tat der kollege buschmann und ich haben
sehr kollege buschmann hat im mit dem
justizministerium sogar das offizielle
verfahren eingeleitet gegen telegramm
was wir nach dem netz dg machen können
dass sie auch verpflichtet sind seiten
zu sperren telegramm hat einen sehr
öffentlichen bereich womit sie zu
protestaktionen gegen
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitiker aufgehoben gegen hass
hetze die morddrohungen gegenüber den
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann und der
ministerpräsidentin schwesig in
mecklenburg vorpommern etwas sehr
widerwärtiges wir haben den öffentlichen
druck so sehr erhöht dass sich telegram
bei uns im innenministerium gemeldet hat
und wir jetzt einen deutschsprachigen
ansprechpartner haben der dann auch auf
unser löschke suchen jetzt die seiten
gelöscht hat das ist ein großer erfolg
dieser bundesregierung wofür ich mich
sehr bedanken sie haben das
dankeschön frau präsidentin ich beziehe
mich noch mal genau auf dieses verfahren
bezüglich des offenen teils von
telegramm und explizit nicht auf den
vertraulichen verschlüsselten
kommunikationsweg ist das jetzt so dass
es auch für die zukunft sichergestellt
ist dass es bei solchen verfahren
einheitliche ansprechpartner bei der em
gibt und ist dort auch von ihrer seite
aus einen kommunikationsweg geschaffen
worden gibt es dort prozesse wie das
andere soziale netzwerke wie facebook
und google für ihren sozialen netzwerk
teil gemacht haben wir haben zumindest
einen festen ansprechpartner wie ich
gerade gesagt habe einen
deutschsprachigen festen ansprechpartner
der unser lösch besuchen über die saiten
dem mord aufrufe und anderes gelöscht
hat das ist ein großer erfolg bgh hat
dort ja eine große gestärkte struktur
aufgebaut um diese verfahren zu führen
was noch nicht so gut geklappt hat ist
in den letzten tagen das was wir im
kriegs zusammenhang gesehen haben dass
auch schnell zu löschen daran sind wir
dran da arbeiten wir dran dass das noch
besser funktioniert
zu einer nachfolge hat der abgeordnete
brandner das boot
dankeschön frau fischer sie haben die
frage gerade gehört manche kommunizieren
über telegramm manche publizieren in
zeitschriften namen des antifa dazu
gehören sie zeitschrift antifa ist ja so
eine zeitschrift einer vereinigung die
der bayerische verfassungsschutz als
bundesweit größte linksextremistisch
beeinflussten
organisation im bereich des
antifaschismus einstuft also nicht ich
mache das sondern der bayerische
verfassungsschutz und diese organisation
wie letztendlich die demokratie
abschaffen weil die demokratie für
faschistisch hält das ist also für meine
ämter meines erachtens die unterstützung
eines magazins ist also schon höchst
problematisch für eine innenministerin
ein skandal das hat meine frage warum
haben sie auch dieses kann da nicht die
konsequenzen gezogen und sie
zurückgetreten
ich beantworte ihnen selbstverständlich
gerne die frage auch wenn ich die nicht
besonders sachlich finde aber ich habe
es vorhin ihrem kollegen schon gesagt
ich habe hier in meiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag sehr klar gemacht
dass ich mich jederzeit gegen jegliche
form von extremismus einsätze gegen
linksextremismus gegen rechtsextremismus
und gegen den islamismus daran gibt es
auch überhaupt keinen zweifel im
gegenteil ich bin schon dafür kritisiert
worden dass können sie gerne
recherchieren weil auch das war unter
meiner zeit als
fraktionsvorsitzendem hessischen landtag
der spd ich habe mich sehr klar hinter
die polizei gestellt als linksextreme
gefährder gerade bei den rodungsarbeiten
im dann oder forst unterwegs waren
vielleicht schauen sie sich das mal an
um sich ein bild zu machen und ich habe
nicht als bundesministerin gehandelt
sage ich auch noch mal dazu
die voraussichtlich letzte frage stellt
der abgeordnete detlef seif
ja frau ministerin ich habe eine frage
zu einem hochaktuellen thema nachdem der
ukrainische botschafter andrej melik
olaf scholz aufgefordert hat eine
regierungserklärung zur aktuellen
situation in der ukraine abzugeben gab
es eine twitter meldung von
staatssekretär sören bartol der unter
anderem gesagt hat ich finde diesen
botschafter botschafter in
anführungszeichen gesetzt mittlerweile
unerträglich so verhält man sich nicht
gegenüber einen befreundeten land ich
halte diese twitter nachricht für
unerträglich wenn ich bedenke dass
dieser botschafter mit herzblut sich für
sein land einsetzt und natürlich alle
möglichkeiten nutzt auch um den
angriffskrieg putins zurückzuweisen und
damit die ukraine letztlich auch
siegreich aus diesem kampf hervorgeht
zwar hat sich der staatssekretär
mittlerweile entschuldigt aber teilen
sie meine meinung dass das nicht
ausreichend ist sondern hier eine
reaktion der bundesregierung erfolgen
muss und man sich offiziell entschuldigt
herr abgeordneter ich finde es richtig
wenn man getwittert hat was er manchem
sehr schnell passiert das wenn man sich
dann auch für äußerungen entschuldigt
dann ist es damit aus meiner sicht
erledigt und ich glaube dass wesentliche
jetzt bei krieg in europa dem furchtbar
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
putins gegen die ukraine hat
insbesondere ja unser bundeskanzler olaf
scholz bewiesen wie sehr an der seite
der ukraine steht und das sollte doch in
diesen tagen im vordergrund stehen und
da sollten wir ihnen alle bei
unterstützen sie haben das gut
dass die dinge im vordergrund stehen
sollten da gebe ich ihnen recht aber in
dieser situation bei diesen äußerungen
muss eine klare rückmeldung der
bundesregierung folgen es ist nicht
damit getan wenn ein mitglied der
bundesregierung solche äußerungen tätigt
das muss offiziell auf dem wege gehen
der entschuldigung alles andere ist
nicht zielführend also werden sie das
zumindest zum thema ihrer koalition
machen und überlegen oder ist das thema
für sie erledigt ich habe in meiner
einschätzung dazu gesagt
[Applaus]
ich beende die befragung danke frau
ministerin
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 3
fragestunde
wenn jetzt um gruppierungen in fraktion
notwendig sind dann bitte ich das zügig
abzuschließen